I'm smiling your I don't hear you
just a minute Oh UI here now okay we
ready
morning the time being 10:05 I want to
open up this work session of the
criminal justice and Public Safety Betty
the New Hampshire House and when a
welcomed members of the committee and
also welcome others who are
participating in this I want to start by
reading a script for purposes of
establishing why we're meeting as chair
of the House criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the Cova 19
pandemic and accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2024 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically now please note that
there is no physical location to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized pursuant to
the governor's emergency order however
in accordance with emergency order I am
confirming that we are a providing
public access to the meeting by
telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means we're utilizing zoom
for this electronic meeting all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by clicking on the following website
address HTTP colon front / front / 0 m
dot u s front slash j front / 9 6 8 6 9
5 0 8 0 2 7 or dialing one of the
following phone numbers 1 9 - 9 205 609
9 or 1 301 7 1 5 8 5 9 to be providing
public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meetings including how to
access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar see
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are problems with access if
anybody has a problem please call to
seven one three six zero zero or email
at HCS at ledge state NHD us a journey
public meeting if a dream if the public
is unable to access access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled I want to
introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting with us pam smiling
senior house community research sarah is
providing the host additional house
communication House committee services
staff providing support our Brad
Greenland Gen 4 and Joel Joel Wright and
Joel Anderson right sorry please note
this is a work session for House bill 11
17 House bill 1580 and House bill 1606
these bills were referred to the
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee as a second committee pursuant
to house rule 46 F I've waived the
public hearings on these bills copies of
the bills and other relevant materials
have been posted on the main page of the
general court website under the heading
remote meetings this also includes
posting of amendments that are proposed
to be considered by the committee
pleased out all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote we're going to start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when what each member states their
presence please also state whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right-to-know law and with that
going to call upon the clerk call the
roll
at the outset I do want to say that
before we do that that under the rules
of the house there is a provision for
people who are unable to attend to have
a substitute appointed the practice is
that those substitutes were appointed by
the leader one recommendation of the
leader of the party of the caucus who
wish their part of and appointed by the
governor by excuse me by the speaker or
the house for the purpose of
participating in this meeting we have
three people who are with us one is
represented in Ober who is kind of a
permanent permanent party she has
replaced represent McNally designed her
position in the first of the year and
representative Ober has been filling
that slot during this session and today
we also joined by representative al
baldesarra who is filling in for
representative Dennis green and
representative Kim rice who is filling
in for representative Dennis fields so
that's that and with that I will ask the
okay I just want to mention that it's
just nine called me just now and for
whatever reason she could hear all of us
and she said but she nobody can hear her
and I guess no she's there she dig it in
I told her to check her email I thought
there was a new link so she must have I
see her okay and okay we will see if she
answers the call yeah excuse excuse me
represent rod that to model it you're
supposed to explain the answer here but
say where you are if anyone else is in
the room with you here I'm here by
myself
so far pat Psilakis here and bang
michelle O'Hearn here at home but
ourselves
clerk i am here with two grandchildren
so I'm not by myself but I'm in the road
by myself at least for this moment a
while was you have to go up in the other
room like I asked you earlier okay
out the back here in the wall
Bourdonnais here at home by myself yes
here and at home and I'm by myself
Murphy here at home by myself no men
here at home and my wife may into the
we can't unmute you from this and
you somebody sent our message didn't she
hear us I don't know if dissonant send a
message to her just tell her to I'm you
and I'll come back to her good idea
Swinburne I'm here at home alone in the
room watch I'm here I got my puppy okay
right I'm here a couple of kids may pass
through and a couple of dogs father saw
her on the air at home
my wife's desk is in my office here but
she's in no Testament Dave Testament I'm
new to some you must be muted on your
here at Macross couples for you here but
I'm in my office Abbess I'm here I'm at
my home my wife Jessica Abbess and my
son Austin Abbas our own they kind of
come in and out but I don't ever lock my
door so there you go right
I'm here and I am a lone in the room
over I'm here I'm in my office at home
Russ is currently out jogging I expect
him back and mr. chairman when you see
the back of my head my working computers
behind me so if I look at an amendment
or a bill you won't see my face you'll
see the back of my head pushing yes I'm
I'm here in my home in Hampton my wife
is here also working on resume meeting
so with that can we try Radice just mine
yes he seems to have dropped off and I'm
hoping that she's rebooting and try
to enter again but I had we haven't
heard from her we tried calling and the
phone went straight to voicemail so
we're working on her we're not
forgetting her but she's not here right
now okay so I I will begin I just want
to outline where we are as the the
committee knows our responsibility as a
second committee the criminal justice
public safety committee is to take a
look at a bill that has passed a policy
committee and has passed the House had
been referred to us and to take a look
at the the fines or the penalties or the
punishment involved in it and make a
recommendation upon that we have three
bills that were in our possession as the
time that the legislature froze up on
those on the 13th of time the
declaration of the state of emergency
was made by the governor that had not
been the subject had not had a a second
public hearing
it is a public hearing for a second
committee bill is optional by tradition
the alleged criminal justice committee
has public hearings on second bills but
other committees do not I know that's
represented over of course is familiar
that it's the policy the Finance
Committee they don't have second
committee hearing bills on bills but
they move to a work session so what I
have done is I have waived the this the
second committee second public hearing
on a bill for those who don't know the
the sense is that a bill that has
already had a public hearing in a policy
committee that there was an opportunity
to have the public give and have input
to that what I've done today in the
instances of House bill 11 17 Hospital
1580 and House bill 1606 has I've
contacted the
chair of the policy committee and the
sponsor of the bill and alerted them to
be you know to the to the work session
that we're having here and as the the
chair of an extended an invitation to
them recognize to participate in our
work session and to provide briefly I
hope a little bit of introduction to to
the bill so that we can become familiar
with it we will you know when the
presentation is made we will you know
function as we would in any in in a work
session that would be taking place in
the legislative office building we try
to ask questions to elicit information
to help us be in our debate and I know
that we're all going to be disciplined
with this it's new as we as we go
forward but with that I do look down at
the screen now and I noticed that
represented radhakrishnan is with us yes
and radically represent Radhakrishna and
the for the purposes of the the clerk's
record can you identify yourself say
where you are and say who's in the room
I'm trying to unmute her I think she
needs to be unmuted on her ends there
you go that's good thank you
I'm here my husband is in the house
somewhere thank you okay great so with
this we're going to take up for the open
up the we're gonna take up as the first
bill in our work session
House bill 11 17 FN which is an act
relative to penalties the dog theft and
tampering with a dogs radio collar I I
know that the the sponsor of the bill
represent of Sullivan had raised his
hand earlier and wished to be recognized
this bill came out of the policy
committee I'm hoping that members of the
of the committee have had
chance to review the research piece that
was done and submitted to us but just
briefly what this bill does it makes
crime of dog theft a Class B felony and
it makes it a crime to remove certain
collars from dogs and a personally who
knowingly gives poisonous substance to a
dog with intent to the dog eating the
substance will be guilty of a Class B
felony and others with that I'm going to
ask representative Solomon and I also
believe I'm going to ask is represent
comptoir here someplace
she find out if somebody from the
environment and Agriculture Committee
which is the policy committee that sent
us this bill if their guard is here okay
by presenting Goa then thank you I did
not know then fine we'll have I guess
I'm gonna ask represent of Solomon to
step in quickly recognize you to explain
to the committee and see if there any
questions then I'll follow that I'm
going to ask the environment
agricultural chair represent for you to
also speak all right Solomon you're with
us and you're unmuted Thank You mr.
chairman and good to see the committee
good to participate with your activities
I am representative Brian Sullivan from
Grantham
and I sponsored the House bill 11:17 on
behalf of a constituent Dianne
Richardson a suspect is also listening
in and she requested this bill because
of the increasing prevalence of people
tampering with the electronic devices on
on various types of dogs many of them
being tracking or hunting dogs that are
out in the woods and apparently some
folks don't approve of the legal
activity that these dogs and their
owners are engaged in and therefore give
a name
increasing basis have been tampering
with the removing the collars damaging
the collars and sometimes stealing the
dogs and this bill as amended by the
environment and the Agriculture
Committee increases the penalty from a
misdemeanor to a Class B felony and I
believe there were some very nice
amendments done by the earlier committee
simplified the bill I think a
streamlined it makes makes it work
better and I would also point out that
not only is it hunting dogs that are
hunting or sporting dogs that are
involved but also people are using these
collars now on on Fido their little
loved pets similar to representative
Welch's snowball and they're they're
putting these collars on in case the dog
gets loose and it allows them to track
the dogs down using GPS you know the
latest technology so I with that I'll
step back and if there are questions I'd
be happy to answer them but I believe
it's good bill that protects the
property of dog owners thank you
are there any hands up no okay
thank you represent Salomon welcome
represent gar you actually come to I
would like to thank you rep recognizer
observe Tompa hey thank you for letting
me speak Thank You mr. chair and
committee members this bill came forth
because theft among dogs is on the rise
people think they're saving dogs by
removing their collars we have hunting
dogs that can be gone for two days
because they're tracking the prey and
the owners have to keep going out
but if a caller is removed they cannot
locate that dog and it could go out and
it has happened where they've run out
into the road and gotten hit and the
owner did not know I just spoke to my
bed actually yesterday and he just
bought a new collar for one of his dogs
it to the tune of fifteen hundred
dollars and that's just for a domestic
dog with the new technology that
represents Sullivan just spoke about
these animals there is no really price
tag that you can put on a lot of these
animals on some of these hunting dogs
you could pay five hundred or a thousand
dollars for them when you buy them but
they're worth a lot more than that and
that is why we just chose to go with the
Class B felony and if anyone has any
questions we just wanted to simplify
that bill and currently under the law
collars can be taken off without penalty
thank you the questions the chair will
ask one then what what was the the the
basis for setting it as a Class B felony
well it is private property
most of these collars that people are
removing are north of $500 people are
also removing microchips
which is a surgical procedure which does
harm to an animal and should not at any
at any time be removed unless it is for
the health of the animal we've also put
in there that if an animal is in
imminent danger that law enforcement
does have the ability to remove that
collar without any penalties but what
has been happening and it's about a two
million dot two million dogs a year are
being stolen it's big business and if we
don't put some teeth into this it'll
continue to happen and it is on the
and we have people that feel like
they're you know they think collars are
cruel or inserting a microchip into an
animal they shouldn't be able to do that
Mike my question right now what's the
current penalty for stealing a dog right
I don't know what the penalty for
stealing a dog is but for taking a
collar or a tracking device off of a dog
or removing a microchip there is no
penalty I understand that I just thank
you I'm sorry are there any other
questions are there any other has a hand
up mr. Welch oh sorry
he's um muted I am trying to unmute him
I don't know why he's not unmuting there
we go all right it says well the steals
are dogs shall be guilty of a Class B
felony I think that's a little strong
for stealing a dog I mean I love my dogs
and I think a Class B felony is a little
bit of overkill on that particular
Romanova one it's a line for the bill I
would strongly recommend a Class A
misdemeanor and again maybe this is
something we can talk about in our well
we haven't
I should make clear that after we
complete our work sessions today on
these three bills then we will move into
an exact session so I I hope asking
questions and not offering opinions
Thank You representative over oh thank
you mr. chairman can either you or
perhaps representative Murphy refresh my
memory we had an animal bill earlier and
we had a penalty in it and I can't
remember what the committee decided what
the penalty was and since I can't
remember the number of the bill I can't
turn around and look it up either so can
one of you refresh my memory thank you
sure actually you know I'm going to look
it up right now I I believe that Julia
Steele is on the phone from the Humane
Society and she was part of writing that
bill I think with representative Rogers
I'll have to look up the number but I do
I do remember if we were talking about
making it a felony for the purposeful
harm to an animal and we looked at
rewriting some of the language in the
animal cruelty bill so it was it was
considered a felony for and and that
that bill actually passed a house so
they maybe we can talk about this
further at our exact session represent
oh I'm not sure that we have tied on't
have the ability right now but I
understand
to the chair and to represent Murphy
that was House bill 1 5 6 0 did you have
more represent over thank you lieutenant
I was a boy who's your hand up ler a
representative a testament had a hand up
and I guess he put it down
representative Abbas has a hand up o
represent a bus and unmute is there we
go just answer the question right now
stealing a dog the penalty is they shall
be guilty of a misdemeanor so my
understanding is the prosecutor or would
have the discretion to prosecute data as
a Class A or Class B misdemeanor
it doesn't say something expressly
stated or be in the RSA so any any other
questions of the committee for all the
sparrow has his hand up represent
baldesarra
Thank You mr. chairman my question is if
you use some of these bags are worth a
thousand to three thousand dollars if
you were to steal
something else worth a thousand all
about there's a net effect considered a
felony also anything else that's a
question to whom to anyone now you guys
do the experts I'm asking you start
something in a store there was a
thousand of more is there a price
difference justify there are I do not
have my question or not know I represent
Boyd has his hand up I don't know I'm
separate thank you I thank you to answer
this question it's mine they would have
to charge the specific charge available
so it is a crime and makes it a
misdemeanor for theft of a dog with no
no increase for value of the dog or not
they have to charge the misdemeanor they
wouldn't be allowed to just go ahead and
call it property when there's a more
specific charge available so right now
as it stands regardless of the value of
the dog it would be a misdemeanor okay
are there other hands up Mike Murphy's
hand is up and also out in the attendees
representative comptoir and
representative Ellen Reid and Jennifer
Smith all have their hands up you know I
just would like to kind of caution we
are under kind of we are under a time
constraint for all of our work today
that we have to be done by 1:30 so I put
that out there and ask people to be
disciplined but go ahead grab some
Testament Testament his hand was up okay
it would not be unusual for a dog in
today's climate to be worth well over a
thousand close to three thousand dollars
I looked at getting a new pup with my
boo BA and that was close to three
thousand dollars
I think that just the cost of that would
get you into the felony range again I
just want to you know remind the
committee we will have an exact session
when we can discuss and offer our you
know perspectives and opinions and help
guide us but we're trying to elicit
information now from people who are
appearing before us to help us guide our
conversation later who else is a hint of
exactly represented Murphy and
Bourdonnais have their hand side and
again if we if grab subordinate very
important I'm looking at penalties for
theft theft of value get DP of services
more than a thousand dollars are a Class
B felony agent there we go
representative Murphy do you have
something and I and again we have people
waiting in line I know that we have I
realize that we're not in the same
situation we would be in a work session
in the Statehouse because this is all
brand-new but we're trying to get
through represent Murphy do you have
something a question of somebody who's
who's testifying something I can't say
in the exact session no no I don't I can
wait thank you
so are there you know Pam smiling miss
Marley has identified that there are
people are the participants who wish to
be recognized again I would I would ask
them to share new information with us if
possible or respond to any questions
that have been posed Pam whoever who's
next
representative Comptoir represent
contrast sorry Rosanna Kahwa made it is
because that um the callers alone were
upwards north of $1500 for a lot of
these dogs and we cannot place a value
in looking at the law and talking with
OLS a class beef
is in line with the dollar amount that
would be would make that the class be
phony so that's why we chose the Class B
felony as the punishment thank you thank
you
there was a read no I see her hand is
disappear well if she's she's not here
I'm underrated hello
there you go be there yes no I I had
just raised my hand when I first entered
the meeting because there was an
incorrect meeting ID number put listed
in the house calendar and I wasn't sure
if other people who were supposed to get
in had gotten in so I just wanted to
clarify that point it wasn't about this
bellows before the hearing is there
anyone else that has anything to add
share with us as part of the work
session
if not we'll I'll wait a minute and Isha
gory has a has a hand up I'm gonna wreck
recognized him to talk and now I don't
chief shibori there we go
he's unmuted is he their Chiefs aghori
no apparently his audio is not working
man he's okay you're you know he's
allowed to talk and he's unmuted so I
don't know why we're not hearing them
all right well I think we'll just kind
of we'll we'll wrap up this this work
session on house for 1117 we'll take it
up and exact later on
an act regulating the use of unmanned
aircraft systems this bill it's it's a
drum bill that we're somewhat familiar
with I know in this committee we've had
we reviewed these in the past I wanna I
believe that represent Brody is going to
speak on behalf of the sponsor
represented McGuire and also the
committee right
I'm represented Rhoda and representative
McGuire are both in these week okay
hands up right now represent McGuire
would the glider I'm the prime sponsor
of 1580 and I'm also on EDMA where this
bill went to the first committee it has
been significantly amended since the
original version and so I'd like to just
point out a few of the things it defines
what an unmanned aircraft system is
based on the federal definition it
requires a warrant for law enforcement
to use a use a drone and it penalizes
putting weapons on a drone or if they
discharge it such a weapon it was
pointed out to me after this bill passed
the house that it might be a good idea
to add a point of intent to that section
because you don't know what a weapon is
until it's used as a weapon there are
some people that have drones with
flamethrowers on them that they use for
pest control and
you know the naive person might think it
flamethrowers an obvious weapon but in
this case it's a tool so but that I
think is something that your committee
is more qualified to deal with them and
I do in this bill clearly gives the
Department of Transportation there are
not experiencing with the FAA and making
and getting new hampshire infrastructure
designated as critical infrastructure on
previous bills as representable the
sarah was pointed out it was thought
that you know like the prison could just
go appeal to the faa but they don't
normally do that the Bureau of
Aeronautics is is capable and familiar
with it they have the skills and the
connections and they'll be able to do it
more effectively and the other thing is
that because most of the issues we've
had from our constituents regarding
drones has been with not with
professionals using them but with your
neighbor play flying a drum that he got
for Christmas around and hovering around
the house and spying in your kitchen
window so to deal with that and to
ensure that the local police can
investigate that sort of thing we
increase the penalty for violation of
privacy in RSA 644 : 9 by making it a
Class A misdemeanor rather than an
unspecified misdemeanor for violation of
privacy if they use a drone and that was
the main thing that affects your I'll
answer any questions I can any questions
represent McGuire oh thank you thank you
mr. chair I'm gonna be very brief we had
five subcommittee meetings on this and
everyone at the end of the Kim the
subcommittee meeting including
representative Maguire seemed seemed
satisfied with the stage of the bill
when we passed it in our committee thank
you any other questions
representative Bourdonnais has his hand
of burning seconds children we all
receive a letter from insurance
representatives yesterday looking for an
exceptions were you steering for
insurance investigations was that
considered as part of this bill yes
thank you
they raised their concerns and they are
part of the exception that also includes
utilities because utilities use this to
check to see if their lines are broken
at any point so they're part of that
group represent Bonnie are you waving
yes I am oh yes so if there are making
these exceptions are there other
exceptions that we should consider
let's just be ready for primetime is
that a question I'm not sure that you
can make the exceptions in the bill are
you know check their work I don't think
that there I think it would be very
difficult to itemize every exception in
the bill this this representative of why
I have a comment on that sorry do you
want me to get representing my lawyer
back your Everett yes please
there we go
yes thank you that specific issue was
not brought to the subcommittee and the
first I saw of it was late yesterday
afternoon when I saw the email I think
that the bill clearly exempts using a
drone on your own property or with the
permission of the of the landowner so I
think that their point of you know
specifically investigating fraud is
something that the is a reasonable
exception and I would support that in
the Senate since that's where they said
they would like to have the details
dealt with I perhaps neglected to state
from the process that's been adopted for
for the purposes of this type of
electronic meaning and the the process
by which a bill that we will consider is
amended is is this a proposed amendment
for a bill that will be the subject of
consideration at a work session or an
exec session virtually under this ritual
circumstances had to be submitted to has
to be submitted to OLS 72 hours before
the notice for the public hearing and
has to be posted on the website 24 hours
the general core information website 24
hours and further as we'll get into
later a bill that will come before a
committee an amendment that comes before
a committee has to be in the name of a
member of the committee for it to be
brought forward that's that's what
that's how that's the protocol that
we're operating under it now so I'll
just say that to the extent that I
appreciate representing McGuire's
suggestion that perhaps the Senate would
address this if we want to proceed for
but I will say that we are not able
today anyhow to take up any amendment
that has not already been submitted mr.
chairman we have representative Muse and
abbess with their hands up represent
mousse followed by represent Ravis
and I'm gonna be eating myself well I
had a question for the sponsors as to
whether or not anyone has or anyone at
the hearing who was a professional
photographer actually testified because
photographing or recording an individual
without that individuals consent for the
purpose of publishing or otherwise
publicly disseminating information like
a photograph is something that virtually
anyone who owns a camera does so it
looks a little broad to me and I'm just
curious if you've got feedback for many
professional photographers or
photographers in general yes the there
were there were a number of
photographers involved and that I said
this bill was significantly amended by
the first committee and they were
relatively accepting of the final
language they would probably like to
have a bigger exception for them but all
things considered we the committee and
the subcommittee figured that we would
get a sketch of the bill that is to get
the basic points that they shouldn't be
out there spying on people but if
they're to you know doing news or taking
you know pictures of real estate which
is one of the main uses for drones that
they do not they're not bad thank you
represent us thank you and this is a
question for any one of the bill
sponsors so I think I'm looking at the
right amendment page two lines one to
five discusses anamur you know an
exception where you know emergency
response you know for safety reasons or
law enforcement investigations so in
that scenario you know law enforcement
wouldn't require a warrant and still
would be able to use these under what I
would say exigent circumstances is that
correct
correct is there any anything in the law
already that addresses law enforcement's
use when it comes to unmanned aircrafts
new hampshire desert because i have a
policy concerning this right now the the
policy is the ruling of the faa and so
the state police was an intricate part
of rewriting this bill so they are
they're satisfied with the way the bill
reads they had a significant amount of
input in the law enforcement portion of
it and represented McGuire has her hand
up I don't know if you want to hear
every time ago I and then I see
represent Baltazar and a her and have
their hands up - thank you thank you mr.
chair the an answer to a question yes
the state police have a drone unit they
have rules on how it is to be used and
they were very insistent that the normal
rules of evidence apply to anything
that's produced with a drone and they
after we modified the bill they're very
perfectly happy with this amendment they
say their operations will all comply
with this with this if it becomes law
maybe one ball - Sarah Thank You mr.
chairman I was reading through the bill
here and trying to find is there an
exception
like for instance I put in a GIS
Commission in the state and cities and
towns use drones to fly other properties
when they do their you know check on you
know for the data they need for the GIS
every time a McGuire recorder yes Thank
You mr. chair yes it's online page 2
line 10 that would fall under incidental
images of private property so that yes
they can fly over over the town and and
mark the boundaries but they can't take
pictures of the sunbathers in the
backyard for example Hearn
just uh I guess either corner or
whatever are we we have this for just
for penalties correct that's correct
okay I'm just know why we're getting so
in depth into the thing where we're just
supposed to discussing whether or not
the penalty is sufficient or not I
appreciate that
that is our focus I perhaps have allowed
a little bit information I think people
may have questions to help them
understand the bill so they can make an
evaluation as to whether or not the
penalty for violating that is
appropriate or not so chairman the only
other hand I see now is representative
Rhoda object Radha I'm willing to I just
want to make the same comment that
representative of our I made was that
page 2 line 10 instead of it's
incidental images of private property is
all-encompassing
I mean encompasses a lot of the things
that also encompasses I know
representative hunt had asked me about
the insurance portion of it and all that
I think falls under line 10 and that's
all I'm gonna say thank you for again
for allowing me to speak anyone else
right we will conclude the work session
on House bill 1580 and we will take up
House bill 16:06 an act relative to
cruelty to a wild animal fish a wild
bird and I again I guess I will
recognize
representative Ellen Reid the sponsor of
1606 Thank You mr. chair can you hear me
yes yes excellent thank you for the
record my name is Ellen Reed
representing Newmarket in new fields so
1606 is a strongly bipartisan bill I
encourage you to look at the list of
co-sponsors what it does is it creates a
common sense criminal penalty to protect
wildlife from those who would inflict
pain and suffering gratuitously for the
sole purpose of inflicting pain and
suffering we have laws like this to
prevent this kind of senseless torture
of captive animals but we are one of
only five states that has no law to
protect this kind of activity against
wildlife so 45 other states have laws
like this already on the books and have
had these laws long-standing as so as it
currently exists in New Hampshire if
someone were to say and I use this as a
because it's a real example ghosts that
a raccoon on fire in the woods there's
almost nothing that our law enforcement
can do in regards to that so and this is
you know we had this discrepancy between
captive animal law and the lack of law
to protect wildlife in spite of the know
that wildlife has all the same nervous
systems all the same capacity for pain
and suffering as captive animals do so
I'd like to go through the brief history
and walk through the the details of this
bill in short I appreciate we just
trying to keep a focus on the on the
panel team we are sure so I can yeah I
can skip to that piece so I wanted to go
through the wording in the penalty so
first of all cruelty I know that from
speaking to some people there is
concerned that maybe the definition of
cruelty might be too nebulous what
constitutes cruelty so first of all the
word cruelty only appears in this bill
as a heading and I did so it's not in
any functioning piece of the bill itself
and I did check with the lawyers at all
of us that there's no that the headings
are not any kind of functional piece of
the bill so
we could we could name this heading
George and it wouldn't make a difference
so the word cruelty in of itself is not
in the legal language of the bill the
language that is used is identical to
the current animal captive animal abuse
statute so we are using long used
language that is defined that is how we
define animal cruelty for captive
animals for for wild animals and that is
specifically to beat cruelly with
torture mutilate and again this has
decades of case precedent so the
definition of wildlife I also wanted to
very briefly touch on that the current
animal cruelty statute that we have
define that the animals are protected
are for domesticated or captive animals
so here instead of using the word
wildlife which includes things like fish
eggs and other things we don't see as
being able to suffer the very specific
wording here is wild animal fish or wild
bird so we have worked very closely with
New Hampshire Fish and Game Department
for the last two years on this language
there's been a long time in drafting and
I believe both the legal counsel for New
Hampshire Fish and Game Paul Sanderson
who drafted the bill as well as Colonel
Jordan who is the head of law
enforcement and Fish and Game are both
on and can answer more questions but we
basically built this bill according to
their input and they actually are the
ones that drafted that so the definition
of wildlife and all of that is and I do
encourage you to to recognize them to
answer questions
so the actual penalty piece so we have
two criminal culpability States out of
the four-color bility states so
purposely to purposely engage in this
activity would be a Class B felony as
you know that is for the absolute most
egregious cases the really gut-wrenching
horrible you know newsworthy cases where
prosecution can prove intent which is
incredibly hard to prove in a court of
law you know you have to get evidence of
planning and what have you and then
originally the the other culpability
state we had said it recklessly to kind
of be as protective as possible of
accidents but actually on the advice of
the department in Colonel Jordan it came
to our attention that actually those who
get intoxicated and then were to go out
and participate in cruelty to wildlife
that those people would not be able to
be prosecuted unless we used negligently
so we reduced that down to negligently
specifically to allow the prosecution of
people who were engaging in this
behavior while intoxicated and that is
an unspecified misdemeanor again to
allow prosecution discretion so in terms
of the hunting community again we worked
closely with members of the hunting
community again I ask you to look at my
list of co-sponsors we've excluded
everything under Title 18 which is the
fish and game titles that includes any
activity even if it were to be
considered cruel if it's done while
engaging in the lawful practice anything
lawful under Title 18 so it's hunting
fishing trapping but also pest
management nuisance animal management
that's all exempted and in addition to
that with the amendment that the Fish
and Game Committee passed we've added an
additional layer of protection for the
huntin community so it's not only title
is tie late-teen exempted but it's also
an affirmative defense and as you know
affirmative defense means that even if
the prosecution can prove the act itself
if the defense can prove that they were
engaged in one of these activities that
the jury would be directed to acquit and
because of that process really helps
prevent any kind of I just want I think
you've made the point a quick question
is the penalty for wild animals the same
as it is for captive animals now so so
the animal cruelty statute for captive
animals is first there's a lot of pieces
of that that would not even apply to
wildlife first of all things like you
know negligence in terms of not
providing housing or not providing
medical care or food or what have you so
none of that is in here the piece that
has to do with actually physically
abusing captive animals and this
actually goes back to the previous
conversation you had on the previous
bill
representative Rogers bill recently
increased which did pass your committee
I believe increased the penalty for
causing the death of an animal up to a
felony so this is this doesn't have to
do with causing death this is
specifically about torturing an animal
and it is on par with the current animal
cruelty statue for captive animals the
the difference is that for the captive
animal statute it's repeated offenses
that cause a felony whereas here it's
the super egregious purposeful and there
were we had four hours of testimony
thank you I realized that we thank you I
respectfully I think that's fine we if
Colonel Jordan if you have somebody else
from Fish and Game who is here who wants
to be recognized I recognize that moment
I thank you I don't know there may be
some questions for you but I want to ask
the question if they are here to
participate and ask them to speak up and
have members of the committee ask any
questions they might have yes awesome
does he wish to address it ready to go
Thank You mr. chairman be happy to
answer any questions the committee
members might have okay does the
committee have any questions thank you I
quit just a quick question I know
everything was covered as far as hunting
and fishing I just wanted to be extra
double careful with regard to for
example ice fishing where we use one
fish to bait to catch another fish is
that still covered in other words from
these shiners
I can't be charged with cruelty to the
shiner because I'm trying to catch
another fish yes representative you are
correct that you can't be the reason for
that is that you're baiting behavior
with regard to that fish is lawful under
Title 18 and also under our
administrative rules so therefore you
could not be subjected to the enhanced
penalties in this proposed statute and
one final question if I may follow up
mr. chair what
well post in other words I said catch a
fish and I quote three or four fish on
my stringer and I told him around the
lake is that covered under the fishing
game is a lawful way of maintaining my
catch until I get back to shore so that
I wouldn't be charged with cruelty for
dragging the fish around the lake behind
I believe that that would be a lawful
activity in from an inland fisheries
point of view with regard to some of the
marine species like a shark or something
that might be something different but of
course if you were in the marine
environment you're subject to an
entirely different set of regulations
but on an inland fisheries situation
that would not be a violation very good
I appreciate it thank you there's a rod
I'm I'm wondering why it's okay to get
drunk and torture or mutilate an animal
what I can tell you representative is
that in our discussions with the policy
committee they wanted the felony
reserved for the most knowing and
intentional types of conduct and the
misdemeanor penalty to be reserved for
all other types of conduct and so rather
than lose an entire case because of
defense of intoxication I was determined
to lower that type of conduct to a
misdemeanor not because it was something
to encourage or excused but because we
did not want to lose the entire offense
to a defense of intoxication
I don't agree but I understand thank you
any more questions
if not thank you very much thanks to
everybody for participating in this work
sessions on House bill 11 17 House bill
1580 and House bill 1606 and with that
and we're back in session I'm going to
open up the executive session and this
being a separate separate activity than
our previous work session I'm going to
for the record read the following as
chair of the House criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee I find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of Cova 19
pandemic and accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 2004 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically please note that there is
no physical location to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with emergency order I'm
confirming that we are providing public
access to the meeting by telephone with
additional access possibilities by video
or other electronic means we are
utilizing zoom for this electronic
meeting all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this session through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
addresses address HTTP s front slash
front slash zo m dot u s front slash J
1/9 six eight six nine five zero eight
zero to seven or dialing one of the
following phone numbers 199 205 609 nine
or one 301 seven one five eight five
nine two and also by providing public
notice of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting we previously gave
notice to the public of the necessary
information for it
this meeting including how to proceed
how to access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar MC
provided a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are any problems with access if
anybody has a problem please call 271
three six zero zero or email at HCS at
ledge dot state dot n h dot u s and
during the public meeting if the public
is unable to attend the meeting in the
event the public is unable to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff around the meeting assisting us
Pam smart ling senior house researcher
is the host and additional health
committee service staff providing
support our Joel Anderson Brad Greenland
and Jen floor so this is an executive
session in House bill
11:17 House bill 1580 House bill 1606
House bill 1601 House bill 1662 and
House bill 1667 the house criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee held
public hearings on HB 1601 House bill
1662 and House bill 1667 on March 5th
2020 and on the remaining bills of
course we just concluded our work
session on that copies of the bills
amendments to House bill 1662 and House
bill 1667 and other relevant materials
have been posted on the main page of the
general court website under the heading
remote meetings please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call and again
with this we're gonna start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there was anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right-to-know law and
with that I will recognize the clerk to
call the roll
attendance
right I'm here and I'm alone pencil
Waka's in here and I'm alone Oh her
[Music]
O'Hearn here at my Rison's alone and the
clerk I am here at my resident with two
grandchildren up the back your no wooden
a here at home alone yes here my wife is
in the house but I'm alone in my office
Murphy here home and alone new men
here at home and my wife is occasionally
in the other room radishes mine
yeah alone in this room my husband is
somewhere in the house
Swinburne here um alone in the room in
my home
well I'm here I'm alone
there's up on my puppy rice I'm here at
home with a couple of kids in a couple
of doors bother Sarah I'm here alone in
my office but my wife is in nope that's
the men I'm here and I'm alone in the
house
Wallace not to employees present but I'm
in my office
Abbas I am here in my house I'm in my
office alone but my wife and son are
Terry okay get yourself on your side I
am here a home in my in Deerfield and
I'm alone in the room over I'm here I'm
home
the joggers gone the grocery store but
my friendly computer cats tried to
disconnect me so we're having a battle
and kissing your mr. chairman your your
muted on your end
I'm here I'm in my home in Hampton in
our house is my wife and we'll go
forward but she's another room I know
we're that we're gonna take up the first
first bill we're gonna take up his house
bill 11:17 an act relative penalties for
dog theft and tampering with dog's
collar I don't know I will just I want
to make maybe I'm making a little
observations about where we are as you
may know obviously we're scheduled to
have a house session on the 11th of July
I think it's it's been recognized that
we have a lot of the house did a lot of
work we we passed a number of bills on
to the Senate we stayed very late on the
until the 13th to do that that having
been said given the constraints of the
pandemic I think it's probably realistic
to say that I'm not sure that the Senate
will give as thoughtful consideration to
the legislation that we had before this
committee and we did the house in the in
the near term given given the workload
that's there so as we proceed in this
executive session I would hope that we
would we would be we would recommend
here
I'm sorry oh I you know I I just I I
think it's fair for us to recognize that
that there's a high probability that the
if there's some concerns about any
particular piece of legislation and we
think we might want to leave it to the
Senate to fix or to send it to address
when it gets there that it won't get
there and that's just you know III say
that just as a rousing the same token I
know our responsibility is to produce
the best product possible for the people
of the state of New Hampshire to craft
good public policy and I would hope that
as we always do with the bills that come
before us that we would make an
appropriate recommendation your respect
you know notwithstanding what we may
think would be the reception across the
wall I don't know if that makes any
sense but I'm just trying to I'm trying
to kind of set the set the stage for the
conversation about these six bills that
we have before us anyways
I I don't know if I realized that we've
had public hearings on all of on these
bills and usually it is but you know as
we know during execs when we have exec
sessions it's only members of the
committee that could speak I always have
within my discretion I believe subject
to the agreement with the rest of
Committee the authority to ask some
someone outside to to weigh in I may or
may not do that now depending upon what
the needs are they require the
discussion but I will just open this up
now I do not have anyone prepared to
make a motion on House bill 1117 but I
would open it up for conversation if
anyone wishes to speak represent
Bourdonnais and they're represented Roy
mr. chairman I'm looking at the
penalties for theft on section 637 : 11
and it appears that the property is
fifteen thousand teen hundred dollars or
more it's considered a Class A felony
and if there's more than a thousand
dollars of less than $1,500 it's
classified as a Class B felony my
problem with the bill right now is that
it would be better to say it would be a
felony rather than classified as a Class
B felony good represent right well I
thought that we were going to be before
we opened it up for discussion we had to
have a motion on the floors I mean
correct with better well it's it's up to
the discretion of the chair I don't
haven't accepted a motion I will I
thought we'd have a conversation for us
again where we're operating in a new
environment I think that had we been
someplace else we would not have a you
know we would have had some time in
between to perhaps have conversations
amongst ourselves but we didn't haven't
had that up you know we just didn't have
that opportunity so I if you know when
we have a conversation I will accept I
will accept the motion but I I've
recognized you have one to speak and I
recognize representative Abbas because
he raised his hand at the time and I
don't know I'll ask for a motion okay
well then I'll speak to the penalty with
regard to making this how much the
animal the dog is worth I think we're
missing the mark a little bit because
it's incredibly difficult to prove I
mean what's the value of a used dog I
mean how do you set a value on a mean it
cost me so much to buy it but what's it
worth now at seven years old I think we
have to look at especially speaking for
myself as a veteran the veteran
community right now there's a lot of
PTSD out there and a lot of people rely
on their dogs and they might not
necessarily be expensive trained dogs
but they are a companion animal and to
have that thing stolen that you rely on
to get through your daily life it ought
to be a felony I think that it should be
a felony I don't think
need to be worrying about how much the
dog was worth how much the call is worth
if someone steals a dog it should be a
felony my opinion I'm so Abbess thank
you so I agree with what representative
Roy said you know figuring out the exact
amount of you know monetary value here
may be difficult but just the basic to
purchase a eight you know purebred dogs
twenty five hundred dollars and up you
know the collar we heard is over five
hundred dollars and then whatever money
you put into training so you know
perceivably you're in at a minimum you
know four or five six thousand dollars
already now think about the mind said
that the individual who would steal
someone's dog it's scared just even
think about it person commits this crime
they know exactly what they're doing
they apparently care less about the
victims property interests they don't
can care less about that person's
emotional attachment to the animal they
know they're taking something that
belongs to someone else and they're
taking that away and you know this is
something that happens this happens more
than you know people really want to talk
about and apparently it's happening more
and the frequency is increasing you know
to deter that conduct you know it should
be at least a Class B felony if not it
sounds from what representative Borden a
suggested that you know if it's anything
else it would actually be a Class A so
it seems like it's even a light penalty
as a Class B felony but at the very
minimum it should be a Class B felony I
resent rice Thank You mr. chairman I
would just like to state that my rescue
dog is priceless to me
so there should not be a price on it
the value she brings to our family in
our home you can't put a dollar sign in
front of
okay thank you any other any other
comments all right
we represent
honey I think you miss Cheerilee I'm not
sure whether you are acceptable to have
them a amendment to this bill but if we
could I would like to amend it to make
it a felony without a class on it
therefore value of the property can be
taken in consideration otherwise if you
someone steals a a dog worth $2,500 with
a collar worth $1,500 actually you
better off just looking at stolen
property because that would be a Class A
felony so the best solution is to get
rid of the designation of a felony a B
Class felony and just make that a felony
well I I appreciate that I will say that
I you know I'm unfortunately under the
current framework to her operating we we
do not have the opportunity to make an
amendment right now the process I lie
that I outlined earlier that was you
know given it was explained made public
is that in this instance as we're
operating in order to provide public
notice to everybody we are required to
have any amendment that we will
considered submitted to OLS 72 hours
before and and 24 hours have it posted
up on the website so that not just this
committee but other members of the
public have the opportunity to do it
it's a way that they try to operate on
under this situation so right now the
that would not be an option so I mean
quite frankly the options that we have
before us now since there has been no
amendment submitted before this
executive session would be to pass the
bill you know our to pass interim study
that's the situation we find ourselves
in representative rod has her hand up
and then represent testerman and then
representative happens I'd like to make
I'd like to make a motion of to pass
represent rod makes a post about to pass
to our representative op de Becque I saw
waved in the screen recognize
representative op de Becque I second
second it okay
so motion about to pass has been made
and seconded is there any further
discussion seeing none of us has a hand
up I'll represent of Abbess I'm sorry
thank you I just to compare this to a
bill that I filed and I know some of us
had some fun with HB 11:23 that was my
cat bill and you know my experience with
that bill is that despite that being
property in law enforcement didn't
always apply your typical property
rights or property destruction of
property to animals so I think it's
although I agree with representative
Bourdonnais that it should fall under
there and I thought it should fall in
there as is that's just not how the law
was being applied you know to disagree
NIT myself in law enforcement
disagreement that's why I filed said
that other bill so I think with this one
you know just be mindful that that it
may not be enforced the way we wanted to
so I think being specific with the type
of felony may be better and you know
maybe we consider whether it should be
an A or B okay as someone else seeing Oh
hands up is that correct Pam that's
correct except for out in the audience
I'm Jennifer Smith well we're gonna I
think we're ready for the vote I can
tell
representative Linda Harriet gasps right
our clerk will call the roll
in favor of the motion ought to pass you
will answer IRA if you're opposed
now you know and the clerk will call the
roll right
yes Antilochus unmute representative
Penta Lucas you've got to do it on your
end all right
I suggest and just leave it as is and
we'll do all the muting for you you
don't don't don't do your muting and
it'll be easier uh-huh uh-huh
we're in the same situation there if you
all right that's right no out the back
yes Bourdonnais yeah yes yes Murphy yes
yes
Swinburne you know Welch considered
watch you'll need to unmute on your end
as well okay
yes feel I'm sorry change papers right
yes
I'll decide yes Testament yes
Wallace yeah
17 to 3 this will have a will it be a
Minority Report okay will we will
represent abroad you'll be responsible
for mid for the reason for doing the
majority report then having made the
motion all right thank you we'll move on
we'll take up a House bill 1580 an act
regulating the use of unmanned aircraft
systems and I'm you know is in the
patent I again we had not heard this I I
will open it up for discussion and then
then I'll take a motion but is there
anyone that wishes to speak on House
bill 1580 represent boy tonight
making sure I understand what the
purpose of this bill was but I think
it's so broadly written that I have to
really be against it I understand the
nuisances of
a drum dating your property is is really
a nuisance but I think that this
if we had a commercial aircraft for
example they could do things that this
drone would be ridden to do so I'm not
further discussion
I don't bother Cyril has a hand up sorry
for the call time
thank you I miss Jim and I think this
bill here it does it a couple of things
here protects the privacy of the
individuals on their property I mean I'm
sitting here here's a small little drone
that my wife uses she's a GIS person I
think we need something law that
protects homeowners you know but at the
same time gives the GIS and others the
you know to be able to police to be able
to use them so it's a win-win on the
privacy part so I have to support it any
further discussion Julie I think
represent radhakrishnan is talking but I
don't see represent Radhakrishna router
Stan you're not we you
you're not unmuted yeah I would like to
know if I a minor you know gets a
birthday present a drone and he's using
it for recreational purposes and he's
under the he's a minor under the age of
say 15 would the penalty be the same for
invasion of privacy a person I would
just say a person who is a minor would
not be that would be a juvenile justice
matter okay represented O'Hearn has his
hand up hope he's never heard you hear
me yes I again I just want to bring up
that all the discussion except for this
last one is not talking about the
penalties and that's what we're supposed
to be discussing is this adequate or not
for the bill that was sent to us second
reading
and in your opinion I'm looking at I'm
strolling with fences whether or not is
it sufficient are there any other hands
up no there aren't
well we will does anyone wish to make a
motion
representative Roy has his hand up boy
I'll bite the bullet I move out the pass
motion is base or second represent
baldasar well members in panel aqus
written seconds there any other we any
further discussion we're ready for the
roll call if you're in favor of the
motion about to pass you'll say yay if
you're opposed you'll say nay
the clerk will call the roll right
yes Pantelis a she's muted she said I
can see I'm reading her lips I think
there she goes just I didn't touch it
you didn't touch it okay I just done
muted it though you've all right how did
you vote since you second of talks okay
oh hello louder oh okay all right that's
right yes out the back
yes Borden Aang no news no Murphy yes
no man
yeah right it's just 9 radishes 9 yes
Swinburne yes
Welch David well yes right yes Baba
Sarah yes
testimon yes Wallis yes
Abbess yes Roy yes / yes and Cushing yes
17 3 7 I'm will to be a Minority Report
again if their minority puts you will
have tilled see this is we do it a
little slow you'll have till tomorrow
afternoon to submit the Minority Report
okay with that
move on to House bill 16:06 FN an act
relative to cruelty to a wild animal
fish or a wild bird again we will I will
just open it up for discussion and have
some discussion then when we're done
I'll open it up for a motion is there
no no discussion am i missing it I don't
see any hands no Murphy has her hand up
represent Murphy Thank You mr. chair I
just have a question as a co-sponsor of
the bill I just want to make that public
disclosure what's my what am I loved how
am I allowed to participate in this well
how are you allowed to participate
you're the fact that you're whether
co-sponsor or not is irrelevant the only
time that we make we take that has an
impact upon our work is when we have a
public hearing we ask if you're a
co-sponsor you either you sit and be an
advocate before the committee explain it
as opposed to sitting and asking
questions to avoid the appearance that
it's that the the public hearing would
not be fair to all participants but and
in your capacity as
member the committee and during exact
sessions you can go for it
thank you there any questions
Thunder rod has her hand up I'd like to
make a motion recognized for motion make
a motion to pass motions been a doctor
pass or a second
I see represented panel artis is waving
I assume that means she wants the second
it's whoever hand if I will ask my run a
second it okay thank you made and
seconded is there any further discussion
if not the the clerk will call the roll
if you're in favor of the motion about
to pass you'll answer by saying yeah if
okay right yes Panther Marcus can tacos
yes Oh her turn
yes how are you cats right yes after
back yes Bourdonnais yeah
Mews yes
Murphy yes no men
yes sorry
Newman Newman ray he's on easy unmuted
I'm muted yeah yes
man it's just nine yes Swinburne yes
well I'm you David yes right yes call to
Sarah
yes Testament yes Wallace yes APIs yes
Roy yes / yes and Cushing yes 20 zero
I'm without objection this bill will
and the clerks ready we'll move on to
the next bill House bill 1601 an act
removing the exception for married
minors from the definition of sexual
assault represent rod I see you have
your hand up no I'm sorry didn't mean to
but did you want to make them I mean all
right in the last vote I think I think
somebody was counted twice but the I
represent abroad has a process question
for the for the clerk was somebody
counted twice other 20 people present
this what I have 20 how many people are
present I have 21 well we only have 20
members of the committee so we okay
that's my mistake sorry okay all right
so this here we are an act
removing the exception for married
minors for the definition of sexual
assault but I see represent of Abbas's
hands up thank you I can't be recognized
to make a motion well I'm I would I was
a customer I've tried to throw it out
for discussion earlier is anyone wish to
to have a discussion first before we
make a motion if no one else does
Murphy just raise your hand I don't know
that I'm sorry I was a little behind
schedule representative abbis
representing Murphy do you ever do just
to speak oh I was just gonna second
representative at mrs. motion the motion
has been made and seconded to ought to
pass on House bill 1601 is there any
discussion I believe we're ready for the
ready for the four to take up roll call
roll call thank you represent remaining
it's called we're gonna chat we'll have
the roll call
yeah if you're in favor of the motion of
ought to pass you'll answer yeah if
you're to pose just say nay and the
clerk will call the roll
fry yes pantalones yes uh-huh yes
sorry that's right yes up the back yes
boyd name yeah muse yes
Murphy yes Newman
radishes lying yes
Swinburne yes
there's there are certain people that
who need to unmute on their and for some
reason we're not able to unmute them
well yes
right yes Father Sarah yes Testament yes
Wallace yes
Abbess yes Roy yes and uber yes
I'm Cushing yes 20 zero without
objection House bills will appear this
will appear on the on the consent
calendar
16:06 now House bill 1660 to enact
relative to the purchase use and
possession of tobacco products this is
where we were going to do something so I
House bill 60 and 62 as some of you may
remember this bill came to us from the
Commerce Committee and it at the time at
the public hearing
there was brought to us an amendment
that was agreed upon by a number of
stakeholders that represented CLE the
prime sponsor of the bill had subsequent
to that had put into a formal draft form
one of the reasons it was done is to
reconcile some differences that existed
between the federal policy and the state
policy and prior to our as we're
preparing to come in to exact session to
take up the bill I had raised the
question about whether the amendment
that was submitted to the committee
originally there was
by representative Klee would be
sufficient for us to act upon and I was
informed that in fact again in the
current rules that any amendments that
we would take up an executive session
had to be requested it had to be drawn
up on the name of a member of the
committee so what I did is I had
representative Cleese bill put under my
name and that is amendment one two four
eight of 2020 and that amendment has
been on the Statehouse website to give
full notice to people I've also had
conversations with the chair of the
Commerce Committee who supports this
amendment with the sponsor of the bill
and with the director of enforcement for
the Liquor Commission which has
jurisdiction over these tobacco products
and for purposes of moving this forward
this is going to be a couple step
process but I'm going to move my move
amendment one two four eight a move to
amend the bill with the amendment and I
and I will recognize representative rod
the amendment so the movement has the
the amendment has been moved and
seconded is there any discussion on the
amendment represent of all the sorrow
and her plaintiff ABA's have their hands
up may be sent ball this hour Thank You
mr. chairman mr. chairman your amendment
deal looks good you could smoke
marijuana medically but if you're a
veteran you serve in war at eighteen
seventeen nineteen twenty up to 21 you
can't smoke cigarettes AE something's
wrong with this here
I don't stand this why we're taking the
right to get away from these veterans
that are fighting wars when we come back
home in New Hampshire they mace
did not Carolina Californian are the
areas but here in New Hampshire they
can't
it's a crying I can't support this and I
previous represented balls are again
that that goes that we can can talk
about that now we can talk about the
amendment team a me talk about the
amount because the member is making a
change for paraphernalia individuals
that could purchase marijuana e-liquids
thank you if I recall correctly and I
hear I have a good memory but a lot of
the tests a lot of the testimony a lot
of the back and forth during the public
hearing we had way back when was that
the federal law is requiring was that
because that the federal law raises
tobacco leash to 21 you know if that's
the motivation for passing this by
adding an amendment to include cannabis
or you know is that's against federal
law I mean the logic of that I mean
forget about your what your position is
on cannabis I'm not going down that road
right now I'm just saying that the logic
behind that's not consistent and you
can't say well we want to pass this and
raise the the backhoe age to 21 because
the federal law says so but then at the
same time whit's add cannabis to it when
that contradicts federal law I mean we I
think to me those are separate and we
should keep him separate and like I said
the logic doesn't line up so I couldn't
I can't support the amendment i I am
looking to see if representative CLE or
someone is present as an attendee that
might want to speak more specifically I
will simply say that I have put in my
name and I'm taking it up because that's
the MEK that's that's the the process
that we're operating under if you see a
handout in the attendee list but it's a
phone number and I can't
by the name of the person okay you want
me to try that or I will oh I found out
I can tell I can look at the attendee
list so now there are two hands out in
the attendees better oh okay I don't
recognize I can't see them on who can
you identify someone it's very difficult
when someone doesn't have their they're
not identified I'm not gonna call on
them if they're I will unless I hear
from somebody from either the agents if
they're somebody from the from the
agency is there anybody is Mark I mean
somebody Abigail Rogers I believe is
from the Department of Health and Human
Services I don't know who yeah Abigail
Rogers has her hand up no more from the
Liquor Commission okay we'll have
someone from the liquor commissioner and
someone from the HHS okay any more from
the Liquor Commission fine please good
day sir I have committee members that
I'll be happy to try to answer any of
your questions I I am NOT able to locate
amendment one two four eight I do have a
numbered one one nine six but is that
represented with cleese name on it yes
it does then the language in one two
four eight is exactly the same as the
language that you have been represented
please okay thank you sir I guess I
would I would I know there's been some
policy questions about the impact but
the amendment as introduced would allow
us to enforce the federal provisions at
the state level and have consistency in
the age which is up to this point
time has been has been a challenge so
I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions that committee members might
have about the amendment and its ability
to be enforced to any members the
committee have it specific question
right yes thank you thank you for taking
my question
I'm just curious if is this law
necessary or is it not move based on the
the current federal I mean why do we
even need this if it's federally illegal
it's illegal is it not well I
respectfully the the way this works is
that there's a couple of it operates at
a couple of different levels first of
all the state enforces the laws using
state law enforcement officers enforce
New Hampshire provisions and under 126 K
we have an age of 19 the federal
provisions have moved to age 21 and
there is no mechanism for whether it's
liquor enforcement or any police officer
in New Hampshire to enforce federal
provisions unless they have been
commissioned with that type of authority
so this bill would increase a state age
to 21 and now provide New Hampshire law
enforcement with a clear and comparable
federal provision to allow for the
enforcement of those laws so we can't we
can't enforce the federal law as a state
of state officer right and I would just
again I want to make the observation
that while we normally do not have
members of the public or anyone else but
members speak during an exact session
I'm making an exception to have provided
information in this instance and so a be
miss Rogers
has a follow-up question sorry right
follow-up yeah thank you just real quick
I just want to do a lot of it I just
want to do a quick listening check so
and my understanding what you said is
it's currently federally illegal to sell
tobacco products at a convenience store
to someone under the age of 21 but the
alcohol Tobacco Liquor Commission can't
enforce that if a store does it because
the state statute doesn't mirror the
federal one is that what I'm hearing
well partially correct if I'm going to
try to make this it's a little more
complicated than that
but I'll try to clarify it and I
apologize for any confusion the Liquor
Commission is the enforcement arm for
federal provisions dealing with the sale
of tobacco so for example the Liquor
Commission will profile perform
al-khattab echo compliance checks with
New Hampshire licensees for the purposes
of compliance with the federal tobacco
laws so when they go out and do that
they're doing that under the federal
authority that they have with an
appropriate Commission and there are
guidelines by which those failures are
reported to the FDA for administrative
action at the federal level if a
compliance check work to be conducted
that was strictly state-based or there
was a an enforcement officer who
happened to go by a store and see a
young person coming out with tobacco
products and challenged them found out
that they were age 18 say for example
then they're moving forward would be on
a state level because they're acting in
a state capacity versus the federal
authority that they have when they're
conducting a dedicated federal check now
I'm not sure if I've clarified that and
I apologize if I've added any confusion
but out
there are essentially two different
paths that this could follow the the
federal path which of course is 21 and
then a purely state path which relies on
state law solely which is now in age 19
and this bill and this amendment would
raise the age to 21 thereby providing
uniformity at the state and federal
level represent baldesarra
I just want to just clarify something on
this amendment am I getting this right
you can smoke cigarettes
you can't smoke cigarettes under 21 well
with this amendment you'll be able to
smoke marijuana under 21 with a medical
card does this mirror federal law well
that's what New Hampshire lawyers
medical marijuana I'm not a hundred
percent certain of the criteria but that
provision was put in there to give
individuals who have been prescribed
medical marijuana as a treatment the
ability to possess it lawfully well said
you have you Hannah represent Welch no I
think if tell me yourself there was a
well sure this is the first time I've
been able to do this happen so I have
manipulate the screen I've had my hand
raised several times and in on the other
bills and it doesn't work David I'm very
sorry I you your hand does not go up on
the screen that I'm looking at the one
that David I will and it's hard to me to
look out at everybody and find out but
yeah I haven't seen your hand either
sort of technical problem going on AC
represent Testament I'm gonna call
represent estimate I'm gonna see
representative Welsh do you have a
question first
actually right now I don't I just want
to get that out all right well well
thank you for drawing attention anyone
else if you if you have you know we're
trying this episode Testament I see you
welcome
I have a question if the senior town
wants to put forward a the city
ordinance that raised it to 21 or
whatever does this affect their ability
no in some cases there are communities
in New Hampshire who have already
byah the ordinance process increase the
age to possess tobacco to 21 so this if
this were to become statute or a law in
New Hampshire it would bring all
communities up to that state provision
of age 21 to possess tobacco products
thank you any other questions for mr.
Moore miss Rogers Hey good morning mrs.
happy Rodgers legislative liaison for
the Department of Public Health Services
I just wanted to let you know that cider
ala is on the line and she is the bureau
chief of the division of population
health and she provided testimony at the
hearing on the bill so I don't know if
you might want to if you see her there
maybe unmute her to take some a question
that that was posed can you find her
damn yes yes I'm sorry I didn't
recognize her before I think hi can you
hear me yes yes thank you so much my
name is for that for the for the cop for
the committee my name is dr. Sasha dalla
and bureau chief for the corporation
health and Community Services and I have
the oversight Donna tobacco prevention
and cessation programs um if the
committee has any specific questions
they can raise but one of the important
thing is to understand that this would
actually align with our this would
mirror the federal t21 legislation that
has been already passed in December and
we are very comfortable with the
legislation because that matters that
our federal legislation and for us the
most important piece is increasing this
age to 21
actually help to save a lot of lives
young lives because has we are looking
at some of our data on youth tobacco
tobacco there is increasing number of
people who are using in 2017 like you
know the number of kids who are
increasing their use of tobacco for the
high school it's almost around quarter
of 25 percent of our high school
students use the tobacco the strictly
the waves or electronic waves so this
actually defines some of that language
and it looks at some of that and helps
to reduce that e-cigarette use in that
in that population and also it out it
also aligns with with a lot of our
thinking about what we understand
current information has the best
evidences not of smokers they start by
age of 18 by increasing this age to 21
that actually helps us to decrease that
and in long term it improves our health
care cost it's almost in New Hampshire
if you look at the cost of smoking cost
health here it's around seven hundred
and twenty nine million dollars per year
so you're looking at the really cost
savings in in long term I thank you I
don't there's any questions I do note
that representative CLE just sent me a
text saying she's on the phone I don't
know if you can find that if she has
anything that she wants to throw in yes
yes we identified her phone number as
the phone er that had raised their hand
earlier but we didn't realize who it was
at first but now and you see it's her
and you know she's unmuted and able to
speak clearly everything was yeah can
you hear me yes okay thank you
yes this bill as it's been stated is
primarily the bill itself is primarily
to put us in line with the federal the
amendment was made per request of DHHS
as they have just stated there and that
was to to do some housekeeping is I
think it was where the way it was put to
me to keep everything in line with what
we have to make all the statutes that we
have kind of equal and in other words
there were certain
items that they'd said one thing and it
was he carried into other items so
that's basically what this amendment
does is house we think the main bill is
to keep us in line with what the federal
has put through to help enforcement as
well as to help the retailer's you know
they've got two sets of standards
they've got a federal twenty one and
they've got a state nineteen and it's
not meant to penalize and and in answer
to questions of well one state has this
and one state has another techno speak
in the federal government has tobacco 21
I am Not sure that I quite shall come to
all addressing the the rolling paper
issue which is kind of what the
housekeeping was but I just wanted to
make what the bill was primarily for so
thank you very much for taking my
comment thank you any discussion I guess
I see you know what we will move first
to the amendment the clerk is ready
clerk ready sorry if you're if you're in
favor amendment 1 to 4 H to House bill
1660 - you'll say yay if you're opposed
you'll say nay mr. chairman yes if
people look on the screen at least on my
screen I'm using a surface pro you can
see a little red symbol in the lower
left of the pictures if it's there you
need to unmute yourself as I muted no
but people are and I think that's why
the clerk is having a little bit of
trouble Pam cannot unmute them as she
said right and I know that we have we've
been through some trainings it seems
like every depending on what your
platform depending whether you're a
computer whether it's a PC whether it's
a mac whether it's an iPad whether it's
an iPhone it seems that they all have a
little different I think that's what's
happening with
the four representatives you know
represent Penta locos I know she you
know she said she's not remute iner self
but somehow she still needs to you know
press her mute barge and get in it must
be a device issue with representatives
Welsh why why don't we why don't we
proceed with the role and then we can
back in before we do anything else about
the mechanical problems we're having
right now represent us have his hand up
I don't you want to have more to say I
don't know let me say about her I just
wanted to clarify I get muted and then I
cannot unmute myself and because it says
that the host will not allow me to
unmute so when you call on me some
reason that finally shows up that the
host will is allowing me I'm you so I'm
not sure exactly what I'm doing wrong
but I really haven't touched it I didn't
try not mute myself let's let's when we
let's get to the roll call and then
we'll then we can take a pause and we
can have a discussion about muting and
unmuting in those questions that's all
again she I could suite her lips and she
said yes I don't know if it's I said yes
yes Ohan yes Harriet Garth right
no up the back yes
Borden egg yeah news yes
Murphy yes new men yes man it's just
can he get through I'm through
what no no rice no baltasar no testimon
yes
Wallace no Avice no Roy no over no and
Cushing yes before I I wanted just to
revisit the questions of technical
different difficulties is there anybody
that's one that has anything they need
to share with us or questions in the
middle of this before we move on to the
voting on the on the bill itself
represent panel aqus yes I just want to
say that mine comes up for media unmuted
the host is muted okay all right we're
learning
I'm just gonna comment I think maybe I'd
be useful if you unmuted everyone and
then see if some people stay muted and
you can't do it as the HOS well we've
been onion I do at the outset of the
roll call I unmute everyone with the
unutilized they so most of you you know
the board clears and you're all unmuted
for the for every roll call but for some
reason those four aren't following along
and I'm not treating anybody differently
and I'm treating no I only I only say
that because I got caught up in in that
a little bit when I when you muted it
and then I muted myself or something and
it just stayed muted but anyway
okay thank you and I'm not sure I I
certainly don't know the solution you
know we seem to be muddling through and
I apologize but we'll we'll definitely
investigate this now oh my god I was
muted you were muted so I was muted
because I was trying to tell you that I
think memory center rice is trying to uh
yeah yes she's unfitted oh thanks so I'm
just wondering if those are they're
staying muted if they're only unmuting
using the space bar because that
automatically puts your mute back on
when you're done speaking they have to
literally unmute and just leave it alone
not hitting the space bar does that make
sense to me I don't it I don't know how
they're I'm you know they're using their
space bars represent well I just didn't
even know I could do that I'd ever heard
in you have you heared up then
again there we go so again when I
whoever is a host its muting and
unmuting I get a prophet says his asking
me to unmute and every time so until you
send me a response somebody's I can't
unmute now I don't I thought we weren't
supposed to be able to be able to touch
anything and I just sit here and you
know every time like after we're talking
you'll it'll say host has muted you but
when it's prompting to unmute got the
way for you to send me a single and I
have to confirm it
yes you know what we are doing we are
unmuting Andry muting everybody but
clearly something is happening with
those four connections and I don't know
why it's acting differently free those
four people's I see David Welch
represent Welch wanting to be unmuted
again identical and I am hitting unmute
there we go I've lost my I can't raise
my hand other than this way so that's
this is all you know obviously this this
is our first official action I'm also
mindful the fact that we're that we're
in an executive committee mode that
there are people who are watching on you
know watching this on YouTube and
YouTube members the public and I would
like us to proceed because we're under
some time constraint so I know we'll all
try to go forward it is representative
rod still on represent rod I'm here so
do I want I'm gonna recognize you for a
motion I make a motion ought to pass as
amended
second by represented panel aqus I see
her hand up discussion I believe on this
and
I will move on to the vote every time
abbis ends up thank you so I've already
explained my disapproval for the
inconsistent logic that applies to you
know he actively deciding what federal
laws you want to fall which ones we
don't
now I also aggrieved representative all
the sorrow above you know members of the
Armed Services I take the position if
you are mature enough to join our
military whether by draft or
volunteering you know that your you
should have the right to you know have
possessed tobacco now many retail is
already requiring the age be 21 because
of licensing issues now I'm not
advocating anyone used to back up
products regardless of your age but we
literally just raise the age to 19 in
September when we passed the budget so
in the reason why I went from 18 to 19
with the idea was to try to keep tobacco
products out of the hands of kids in
high school youth so we don't even
really know the impact but the health
and social policies aside you know this
does raise it a constitutional issue
that we all can appreciate and there are
people right now who are you know ages
19 to 20 who are already in possession
of tobacco products so what is what they
are lawfully possessing today will
become illegal upon this bill becoming
law now you know article 23 of our own
State Constitution it says you know
retrospective laws are highly an
interest oppressive and unjust now but
what that really amounts to it's it's
called the constitutional taking you
know in order to do that you know that
person is entitled to just compensation
now I understand you know the health
concerns behind this but from a
constitutional perspective we're taking
someone's property interest away from
them and literally giving them a provide
them nothing in return
now that we can address that with an
amendment and not apply it the people
who are already in possession of it but
I'm just explaining that you know on its
face as written
I consider this bill to be
unconstitutional because we're simply
not offering that person the
compensation so morals and emotions
aside this bill really should be ITL
because it's just it's clearly
unconstitutional so the first person is
charged with that offense whether it's a
fine whatever they have an argument a
made right okay represent analogous
thank you I thought we were just looking
at the penalties where we're we're in
we're the motion on the floor is on to
pass with amendment okay but we're
supposed to just look at the penalties
not whether its constitutional or
anything like that right we're we're
we're just we're discussing whether to
build a lot to pass with amendment right
any further discussion all right then
we've got hands up mr. chairman this guy
represents winburn if I recall in
reading over the bill it phases it in so
that people who are now 20 have a year
before it applies to them and people who
are smoking and our 19 have two years I
I can't look up the bill and keep all of
you on my screen so I may not be
remembering accurately but that was my
impression I don't know no again I don't
have an answer to that
yeah representative over chairman I do
think that when a bill is
unconstitutional there is a penalty with
it and there are some concerns
constitutionally with this bill that
unfortunately we did not have an
opportunity to have a constitutional
attorney talk to us so I can share
my colleagues comments about concerns
and where we might be going as a state
Thank You mr. chairman thank you very
much
I represent baldesarra Thank You mr.
chairman I'm looking under page three
we're under a line 11 that says no
person shall sell Gilbert earnest
tobacco products
he cigarettes or he liquid to a person
who has not attained 21 years I don't
see any type of a year or two year you
know breaking the thing there my concern
is this here bill you know is a
feel-good bill we're worried about
anyone's health when New Hampshire is a
personal responsibility state we have a
no seatbelt no helmet we're going
against the way hypocrites on one end
saying you can smoke medical marijuana
okay you have a medical card but you
can't get in the military with that but
yet if you're in the military forget it
you shouldn't be smoking we're bein
brainy's or nannies I can't support this
thank you
further discussion I was Abbess to the
extent of my thank you the extent of my
comments were not topical any when it
comes to penalties or punishments you
know whether it's a fine misdemeanor or
felony if the bill is unconstitutional
there shouldn't be any penalty fine
whether misdemeanor or felony that's
just my thought for the discussion it's
not I guess we're we're ready for the
vote if you're in favor of the motion of
ought to pass with amendment
yay if you're opposed you'll say no it
right yes and tamarcus yes O'Hearn exam
I heard yes Harriet gasps all right no
out the back
yes wouldn't a no yes yes
Murphy yes new men
she's nine yes
Swinburne no watch
Oh rice no Baldassare no testimon Oh
Wallace no APIs no Roy
no / no and Cushing yes 9 yeas 11 nays
motion fails representative panel
artists wish to move interim study now
represent
like I see you unmuted we're working on
it here does represent a broad wish to
move interim study so I'll move interim
moved in a second an interim study any
discussion
well I mean if we want to just pass it
you know have a study you know I
understand I'm not sure how much
studying is to be going on given the
circumstances right now I mean to me
this is then if we pass it's gonna then
go through the Senate as we heard at the
beginning of the onset that they have a
lot of responsibilities and they're
gonna have to somewhat you know pick and
choose with what takes priority here so
we can keep this off their plate you
know okay we should do it in itla well
any any further discussion I think we'll
try to move on to move the question
represented Penta locos has her hand up
and she's unmuted I for some reason I
can't get I my something's covering
representative panel aqus unlike someone
like that I can't control that I just
want to say that I agree with this area
it probably is unconstitutional but it's
been joy committee before us and I was
only trying to protect the store owners
that I have to do deal with this thank
you right so we'll we're gonna move on
we're gonna have the vote if you're in
favor of interim study you'll say yeah
if you're opposed you'll say nay clerk
Antiochus yes uh-huh
yes Harry gasps right yes pop the back
yes
wouldn't a no yes yes
Murphy yes Newman yes
Welch
no rice no BOTS i/o testimon no Wallace
no Abbas no Roy no / no Cushing
yes rod yes sorry right so we have 2 4 6
8 10 11 11 9 will they be a Minority
Report if the minority reports gonna be
done again would I'm gonna ask to be
submitted by close of business tomorrow
afternoon
next I'll move on to House bill 1667
this is another bill that has an
amendment that was posted on the General
Court website and I'll recognize
representative Wells from a motion got
his hand up and we're working on the
unmuting oh good I don't know what's
going on here with him same but not very
satisfactory I'd like to make a motion
and
that would be with amendment 1 2 4 9 H
was at 16 62 or 1667 1 2 4 9 H I'm again
not to deviate but I believe I'm not
sure Pam would you check is representing
Sykes on the on the list he's that the
chair of the Commerce of the
Transportation Committee from which this
bill came he would just be available if
we had any questions I don't know if
he's still there I haven't seen it if he
is I'd want to Rocky
I do not see him unless he's one of the
phone callers there are two phone
callers well we will we will address the
Welch we met them the motion by
representative Welch we can have to some
discussion we can have that and move on
to to vote on the amendment represent
well sir do you want to speak to you to
the amendment for a second is there a
second yes I see represent Bourdonnais
is waving his hands all right under the
the bill has a study committee to look
at whether or not participants and drug
court would be able to get a restricted
license so they can attend the functions
of their sign and there's not going to
be any study committee set up so the
amendment removes the study committee
from the bill I think and I you know
that representative Welch speaks to
something that I neglected to mention
earlier there has been a suggestion that
any bills that contain Study committee's
will not pass this session and that's
just kind of a realization we did not
want to get the
fact that I believe that the purpose is
to make sure that the fact that a bill
included a Study Committee component did
not get in the way of what otherwise was
a sound underlying public policy that
should be advanced representative Ober
has her hand up I'm saying over sorry I
had to step out to take the phone call
John courts get a grant from the state
to operate this supposed to cover all
their expenses there has been a group
called friends of the drug court who
have done fundraising and have provided
funding for participants in drug court
who don't have a license to be able to
go to mandated drug court events etc I
had a phone conversation with Chief
Justice Tina and Ned al she called me
not about this bill but she called me
because with the pandemic the Friends of
the drug court are not able to raise
money and she just wanted me to know
that they had enough surplus in their
grants that they were going to start to
pay for transportation for these people
to go to mandated events I don't know if
that's sustainable for her in the long
haul but it was the only way she could
keep drug court going I think there's
some thought if we think drug courts are
viable to supporting the amendment and
moving it forward Thank You mr. chairman
I would I would note that the the bill
the the amendment strip simply removes
the study commission for the for the
drug court for a special we call them
Cinderella license which you know can
separate apart from this doesn't does
not mean that the underlying bill which
provides additional flexibility for the
reinstatement of licenses or address
that shouldn't go forward follow-up sir
yes yes I recognize that but since that
is a study committee and it's likely
given our current legislative
we should set a study committee could
stall an entire bill I question whether
we would want to stall an entire bill
that had some things we all agreed with
and so I supported removing this study
committee thank you for letting me
clarify thank you very much there any
other any other questions seeing none
the clerk the clerk's ready will call
the roll no I miss anybody if you're in
favor Lansing okay if you're in favor of
the motion by representative Wells to
adopt the amendment you'll say yay if
you're posed you'll say they right yes
pan Psilakis yes Oh her yes Kurt yes up
the back
yes would name yeah news yes Murphy yes
Newman
yes radishes 9 yes
Swinburne yes Welch yes feel I'm sorry
right yes about the Sarah yes Testament
yes Wallace yes yes Roy
yes Ober yes and Cushing yes 2009 Welch
promotion
and we'll want to pass as amended
second by represent Swinburne any
discussion we're ready when the clerk is
can I have the amendment number 1 2 4 9
H right yes Antilochus yes uh-huh
yes clerk yes out the back yes Gordon a
yes yes yes Murphy yes no men yes right
it's just nine yes
Swinburne yes vouch yes
rice yes Baltasar yes Testament yes
Wallace yes Abbess yes Roy yes / yes and
Cushing yes 20 zero without objection
House bill 1667 will appear on the
consent calendar this concludes our the
work on our executive session at the
outside I just want to say thank you to
everybody for their hard work and
participation in this it was our first
foray into meeting virtually both to
have a work session and an exec session
and I think it I think it went I think
it went pretty well I know we're
learning a lot all the technical
problems are going to take a while for
us to work out but it's it's good to
know that that we can function I will
tell members the committee I have we
have in our possession two
Senate bills that are that have been
sent to us I also know that queued up
are our four bills anyways that have
been passed by the Senate that have not
yet formally been transmitted to the
house for introduction and referral to
our committee and I also know that from
conversations that there a number of
other Senate bills that would be
destined for our committee should that
take place should the Senate get back
into into action I think the house is a
little bit ahead of the Senate right now
in that regards I've asked to have to be
able to schedule our public hearings on
the two Senate bills as soon as possible
and we'll see what will happen I don't
know if anyone else had anything other
Beth you have your hand up if the clerk
would just over who has to write what
reports which already many reports very
you looking to be busy represent abroad
Harriet are you able to do that no no I
just got to go through all this
paperwork I don't know if there are any
minority reports that are coming in but
I get them to me by myself and Karen by
tomorrow at 4:30 and and the Rae and
also the majority reports themselves
should go in by 4:30 p.m. on she Karen
Roy has 1580 ride has 11:17 I'll get you
Laurie hey Cushing has or rod one of the
other hats 1662 rod right okay yeah
right
and Welch has 1667 which one am i
missing the one interim that I believe
it's the 16 Oh you 1662 I did 1662 bit
night went rod 1662 is rod right so we
have one one one seven rods one five
eight oh boy one six oh six is Abbas
Abbas Abbas when 6:06 is Abbas okay once
601 is who I have rod
alright ride is 1 601 okay one six okay
we're good I'll get I know I'm gonna get
representative panel Walker's head or
hand up and I see representative all the
sow has his hand up also I just wanted
to say thank you to patch damn she did a
great job in you and say hey everyone
okay I will thank you very much thanks
for being
occasion with the muting yeah thank you
everybody this has been really represent
bob lazar oh yeah mr. chairman under
1667 I didn't I make a note here is that
going on consent calendar yes it is okay
yeah thank you was an honor serving with
you once again it's always a pleasure
representing the poem and it's a
pleasure representative rice to have you
here with us
yes it's a good crew is there anything
else if not Lordy a final word yeah I
want to say thank you to Linda she did a
great job in the circumstances Oh Scott
represent Wallace has his hand up Scott
huh
the same just wanted to say nice to work
with everybody again hope everybody is
low and good to see you Laura
yeah there were seven Newman I just like
to thank the clerk I did her job once
and I don't want to do it again I'll
second that I'm thinking Linda I'm very
glad I I have rely represent of Murphy
to help organize my paperwork so she can
do that remotely so I'm just confused
am i I thought I was gonna write the
report the majority for 1601 is that it
is 1601 yeah that's right yes all right
I had 1606 and I had 1601 go with your
whatever when you sat 16 what you had 16
on 6 or 7 I didn't make the motion on
1606 right we made the motion you're
get my paperwork together here
maybe my fellow co-sponsor represented
Murphy wants to write it we're both
freshmen so I can say I think it was Ron
and Penta latkes
at the pet pass right 16:01 represent no
lip Jim yeah but she made 1601 you
played the motion Alice did 1601 I had
that so she happily 1606 and and on 1606
I had a twenty20 was that right yeah
yeah okay so was odd to pass move by
representative rod and representative
Pantanal office never said rod has that
one I think we're all set everybody aim
thank you all very much
I look forward to seeing you all very
soon